PRESIDENT, WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AS WELL.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE JUST COMPLETED A VERY GOOD
MEETING OF THE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE, AND WE, WE’RE REALLY,
THEY’RE REALLY DOING A GREAT
JOB, OUR PROFESSIONALS.
THE RESULTS ARE VERY, VERY, VERY
GOOD, AND WHEN YOU COMPARE THIS
TO WHAT’S HAPPENING AROUND THE
WORLD, WE’RE VERY PROUD OF OUR
PEOPLE.
IT’S BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
COORDINATION WITH STATES, WITH
CITIES, AND THEY’RE A LITTLE
SMALLER FORM OF GOVERNMENT, AND
THINGS ARE GOING WELL.
THEY’RE COORDINATING WITH US AND
CERTAINLY IN PARTICULAR I THINK
CALIFORNIA’S BEEN TERRIFIC, THE
RELATIONSHIP.
NEW YORK HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD.
WE’VE HAD SOME REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS IN TERMS OF
ESPECIALLY THE HOT SPOTS, AND
WE’RE FOCUSED ON THOSE HOT
SPOTS.
SOME AREAS WE HAVE NO PROBLEM
WHATSOEVER, AND WE HOPE TO KEEP
IT THAT WAY.
BEFORE I TURN THIS OVER TO OUR
GREAT VICE PRESIDENT TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE, I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
HARD WORK DONE BY THE PEOPLE
BEHIND ME AND THE PEOPLE BACK IN
THE VARIOUS OFFICES INCLUDING
BACK THERE, I JUST LEFT THE OVAL
OFFICE.
WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE THERE THE
THAT ARE PROBABLY WATCHING THIS,
OR THEY’RE JUST WORKING.
WE’RE USING THE FULL POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DEFEAT
THE VIRUS, AND THAT’S WHAT WE’VE
BEEN DOING.
LAST WEEK WE SECURED AN INITIAL
$8.3 BILLION FROM CONGRESS FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS, AND THAT WAS
QUICKLY DONE AND VERY
EFFICIENTLY DONE.
I WANT TO THANK ALL MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
YESTERDAY I DECLARED A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY WHICH WAS A VERY BIG
DEAL BECAUSE IT OPENED UP
AVENUES THAT WE WOULD NEVER BE
ABLE TO OPEN UP WITHOUT IT, AND
IT WILL MAKE IT MORE, IT’LL MAKE
MORE THAN $50 BILLION AVAILABLE
TO US IMMEDIATELY IN DISASTER
RELIEF FUNDS, AND THAT’S
AVAILABLE FOR STATES,
TERRITORIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
SO THAT WAS REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
WE ALSO REACHED AN AGREEMENT
YESTERDAY ON A NEW LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THAT WILL PROVIDE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES IN DEALING WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS.
SO THAT WAS DONE VERY, VERY
BIPARTISAN.
IT WAS VERY NICE TO SEE IT.
PROBABLY THE COOPERATION, I WANT
TO THANK SECRETARY OF TREASURY
STEVE MNUCHIN WHO DID A
FANTASTIC JOB AND WORKED WITH
NANCY PELOSI AND
REPRESENTATIVES, IS SO IT WAS
REALLY GREAT, WORKED OUT REALLY
WELL.
A LOT OF PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
WHICH THEY’RE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING WITH YOU TODAY, AND
THEY’RE TREMENDOUS PROVISIONS.
SO THAT’S SOMETHING WE SHOULD
TALK ABOUT.
I WAS HONORED TO SEE THAT THE
STOCK THE MARKET -- YOU WERE
MOSTLY THERE WITH US -- SET A
RECORD IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
OVER A 45-MINUTE PERIOD THAT WE
HAD THE PRESS CONFERENCE
YESTERDAY IN THE ROSE GARDEN.
THAT WAS A RECORD, ALL-TIME
RECORD.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO ONE OF THEM
EVERY DAY, PERHAPS.
HOW ABOUT FIVE TIMES A DAY?
WE’LL DO ONE FIVE TIMES A DAY.
BUT THAT WAS SOMETHING TO WATCH.
I HAD NO IDEA.
WE WALKED BACK, I SAID SO HOW
DID THAT WORK OUT.
THEY SAID, SIR, YOU JUST SET A
NEW RECORD IN THE HISTORY OF THE
STOCK MARKET, SO THAT WAS PRETTY
GOOD.
AND THOSE GREAT COMPANIES THAT
WERE THERE, THEY COULDN’T HAVE
BEEN TOO UNHAPPY EITHER WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY’RE
ALL VERY BIG, PUBLICLY-LISTED
COMPANIES, SO THEY DID A GOOD
JOB.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY’RE
GOING TO DO A GOOD JOB WHEN YOU
LOOK AT CVS AND WALMART AND ALL
OF THE TREMENDOUS PEOPLE THAT
WERE THERE YESTERDAY.
THESE ARE THE BIGGEST AND THE
BEST, AND THEY’RE OPENING UP
THEIR FACILITIES, THEY’RE
OPENING UP -- THEY’RE RIGHT NOW
LITERALLY WORKING RIGHT NOW ON
OPENING, DOING SOMETHING THAT’S
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE’RE DOING IT.
AND SO WE’RE VERY PROUD OF THEM.
ALSO THE BILL PROVIDES FOR FREE
CORONAVIRUS TESTING FOR ALL
AMERICANS WHO SHOULD BE TESTED.
SO PEOPLE THAT ARE GETTING
TESTED ARE GETTING THIS FREE.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO PAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT’S A LOT OF
MONEY, AND IT IS, YOU KNOW, IT’S
A PRETTY COMPLEX TEST ACTUALLY.
IT COSTS MONEY, AND IT’S BEING
PROVIDED FREE.
SO PEOPLE DON’T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT.
IT ALSO PROVIDES PAID SICK AND
AND FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE FOR
THOSE WHO NEED IT INCLUDING FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE THE VIRUS, FOR
CAREGIVERS AND THOSE LOOKING
AFTER CHILDREN AFFECTED BY
SCHOOL CLOSURES.
SO THAT’S ALL TAKEN CARE OF
ALSO.
AND WE’LL CONTINUE ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT ACTIONS.
EVERY WE HAVE OTHER THINGS
PLANNED.
WE’RE GOING TO ALSO BE WORKING
WITH COMPANIES THAT ARE AFFECTED
FINANCIALLY.
OUR COUNTRY IS IN THE BEST
FINANCIAL SHAPE WE’VE -- SO
DIFFERENT THAN IN THE PAST OVER
THE YEARS IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF
THE REAL BIG CRISES WE HAD, IT
WAS FINANCIAL PROBLEMS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS.
WE NOW ARE IN VERY, VERY STRONG
FINANCIAL SHAPE WITH ALL OF THE
TRADE AND ALL OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE’VE BEEN DOING.
IT’S BEEN PRETTY AMAZING.
WE HOPE THE FEDERAL RESERVE WILL
FINALLY GET ONBOARD AND DO WHAT
THEY SHOULD DO BECAUSE WE’RE
DOING THINGS THAT THEY SHOULD BE
DOING, FRANKLY, AND WE CAN ALL
DO THEM TOGETHER.
BUT THEY SHOULD BE MUCH MORE
PROACTIVE.
OTHER BOARDS IN OTHER COUNTRIES
AND PEOPLE REPRESENTING THOSE
COUNTRIES ARE TAKING A MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE ACTION THAN OUR FED,
AND FOR THE MOST PART, SO WE’D
LIKE TO SEE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
LOOK AT CENTRAL BANKS YESTERDAY
WHAT THEY DID, WE WANT TO SEE
OUR FEDERAL RESERVE BE MUCH MORE
PROACTIVE.
IT’S IMPORTANTMENT BUT IN THE
MEANTIME -- IT’S IMPORTANT.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, WE’RE DOING
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN REALLY
WELL RECEIVED.
I GUESS YOU SAW THAT YESTERDAY
AT THE END OF THE DAY WITH WHAT
WE’VE DONE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS TO TELL
YOU IN TERMS OF RESPIRATORS, IN
TERMS OF ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
THINGS, THE MAXES ARE BEING --
MASKS ARE BEING MADE BY THE
MILLIONS, MILLIONS AND MILLIONS.
WE HAVE PLENTY NOW, BUT WE’RE
ORDERING MILLIONS.
WE’RE ORDERING WORST CASE
SCENARIO.
WE ALWAYS SAY WORST CASE
AND THAT’S WHERE WE’RE GOING.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY.
I THINK THE PRESS HAS BEEN
REALLY -- OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS
I THINK THE REPRESENTATION’S
REALLY BEEN VERY FAIR FOR THE
MOST PART, BEEN VERY FAIR.
WE’RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
IT’S SOMETHING THAT NOBODY
EXPECTED.
IT CAME OUT OF CHINA, AND IT’S
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT HAPPEN.
NOBODY’S FAULT.
WE ALL WILL SOLVE THIS PROBLEM,
WE’LL SOLVE IT WELL.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLE IN THE WAY
THEY’VE ACTED.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT COMPANIES AND
SPORTS LEAGUES AND ALL OF THE
THINGS, WHAT THEY’VE DONE IS
JUST SOMETHING VERY SPECIAL.
WITH THAT BEING TOLD -- WITHOUT
BEING TOLD NECESSARILY.
IN SOME CASES PERHAPS THEY WERE
TOLD, BUT FOR THE MOST PART THEY
WANT TO GET IT OVER WITH QUICKLY
AND WITH VERY LITTLE DEATH.
AS OF THIS MOMENT WE HAVE 50
DEATHS WHICH IS A LOT OF GOOD
DECISIONS WERE MADE OR THAT
NUMBER COULD BE MANY TIMES THAT.
THAT’S BASED ON A LOT OF GOOD
DECISIONS.
ONE OR TWO IN PARTICULAR.
YOU KNOW THAT EUROPE WAS
DECLARED THE HOT SPOT YESTERDAY,
A BIG HOT SPOT AND NUMBER ONE,
AND WE, WE MADE A DECISION QUITE
A BIT PRIOR TO THAT WHEN WE SAW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
BUT IF YOU HAVE YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS -- YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS, THIS GROUP WILL BE
VERY HAPPY TO DO IT.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY THEY HAVE
BEEN LED BY MIKE PENCE.
THEY HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE.
THE JOB THEY’RE DOING, THEY’RE
WORKING 20 HOURS A DAY.
THIS MAN IS WORKING 20 HOURS A
DAY OR MAYBE MORE.
IS IT MORE?
TONY’S BEEN WORKING, I’M JUST
LOOKING AT THIS WHOLE GROUP, AND
WE’VE CREATED A NUMBER OF NEW
STARS INCLUDING THE GENTLEMAN
RIGHT BEHIND ME.
I WATCHED HIM THE OTHER DAY.
SUCH A FANTASTIC JOB YOU DID.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
BUT THEY’RE GOING TO BE
ANSWERING QUESTIONS, AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF NEW INFORMATION, SO I
THINK YOU’LL FIND IT VERY
INTERESTING, AND I’LL BE GOING
BACK TO THE OVAL OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> PRIME MINISTER, THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
RUSHING TO COSTCO, RUSHING TO
GROCERY STORES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, FILLING UP THEIR
BASKETS.
DO YOU THINK PEOPLE SHOULD MAYBE
CON VERVE AS OPPOSED TO BUY?
ALSO OVERNIGHT APPLE SAID
THEY’RE GOING TO BE CLOSING
THEIR STORES FOR TWO WEEKS.
DO YOU WANT TO SEE OTHER RETAIL
OUTLETS DO THE SAME THING?
>> I THINK, FRANKLY, IT’S GOOD
IF THEY DO IT.
I I THINK WHAT APPLE DID IS
GOOD.
WHEN IT GETS BETTER --
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
>> WELL, PEOPLE ARE GOING AND
BUYING THINGS, AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT.
BY THE WAY, I HAD MY TEMPERATURE
TAKEN COMING INTO THE ROOM --
>> SO DID WE.
>> YOU DID?
GOOD.
LET’S COMPARE.
THAT MEANS WE’RE ALL LOOKING
GOOD.
I ALSO TOOK THE TEST LAST
NIGHT --
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> YEAH.
AND I DECIDED I SHOULD BASED ON
THE PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY.
PEOPLE WERE ASKING DID I TAKE
THE TEST.
I DON’T KNOW, WHATEVER IT TAKES,
A DAY, TWO THE DAYS, WHATEVER IT
IS.
THEY SENT IT TO A LAB.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, SENDING MIXED
MESSAGES.
YOU SHOOK HANDS WITH PEOPLE
YESTERDAYING YOU HAVE TALKED
ABOUT FIVE MILLION TESTS BEING
AVAILABLE BUT WE WON’T NEED THAT
MANY.
HAS YOUR OWN SENSE OF URGENCY
INVOLVED, AND ARE YOU CHANGING
WHAT YOU’RE DOING?
>> THIS WAS URGENT FOR ME RIGHT
FROM THE BEGINNING.
YOU KNOW THAT BECAUSE I CLOSED
UP OUR COUNTRY TO CHINA.
>> BUT WHY ARE YOU SHAKING
HANDS, SIR?
>> BECAUSE IT ALMOST BECOMES A
HABIT AND YOU GET OUT OF THAT
HABIT AND, FRANKLY, I WAS A
NON-HANDSHAKER FOR THE MOST
PART.
I NEVER BELIEVED IN IT, AND ONCE
YOU BECOME A POLL DECISION,
POLITICAL PEOPLE COME UP TO ME,
THEY WANT TO SHAKE MY HAND.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> JUST WAIT A MINUTE.
JUST TALK IT NICE AND EASY,
OKAY?
JUST RELAX.
PEOPLE COME UP TO ME, THEY SHAKE
HANDS, THEY PUT THEIR HAND OUT.
IT’S SORT OF A NATURAL REFLEX.
AND WE’RE ALL GETTING OUT OF IT.
ALL OF US HAVE THAT PROBLEM.
SOMEBODY COMES UP TO YOU, THEY
PUT THEIR HAND OUT, YOU PROBABLY
TEND TO SHAKE IT.
AND WE’RE ALL GETTING OUT OF
THAT.
SHAKING HANDS IS NOT A GREAT
THING TO BE DOING RIGHT NOW, I
AGREE.
BUT SOMETIMES I’LL PUT THE HAND
OUT, OR YOU DON’T THINK ABOUT
IT.
PEOPLE ARE THINKING ABOUT IT
MORE AND MORE.
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT, IT’S
IMPORTANT.
SOMEBODY SAID YESTERDAY I
TOUCHED THE MICROPHONE.
I WAS TOUCHING IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE DIFFERENT HEIGHT PEOPLE,
AND I’M TRYING TO MAKE IT EASY
FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY WOULDN’T
BE ABLE TO REACH THE MIC, THEY
WOULDN’T BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN THE
MIC.
SO I MOVED THE MIC DOWN, AND
THEY SAID, OH, HE TOUCHED THE
MICROPHONE.
WELL, IF I DON’T TOUCH IT,
SOMEBODY’S GOING TO HAVE TO, SO
I MIGHT AS WELL BE THE ONE TO DO
IT.
BUT, NO, WE ALL HAVE TO GET AWAY
FROM -- I MEAN, GETTING AWAY
FROM SHAKING HANDS IS A GOOD
THING, AND POSSIBLY THAT’S
SOMETHING THAT COMES OUT OF
THIS.
MAYBE PEOPLE SHOULDN’T BE
SHAKING HANDS FOR THE LONG TERM
BECAUSE IT DOES TRANSMIT FLU AND
OTHER THINGS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE FLU IN OUR
COUNTRY THAT KILLS ON AVERAGE
36,000 PEOPLE A YEAR.
36,000 PEOPLE.
AND, YOU KNOW, THATS’ SOMETHING
THAT WE’RE NOT TALKING ABOUT --
THAT’S SOMETHING WE’RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
AS OF THIS MOMENT WE’VE LOST 50,
POSSIBLY LESS THAN, BUT PROBABLY
50 PEOPLE, AND WE’RE GOING THE
TRY AND KEEP THAT NUMBER AS LOW
AS POSSIBLE.
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> DEPENDING ON, DEPENDING ON
TELLING SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES NOT TO TRAVEL
DOMESTICALLY, SHOULD ALL
AMERICANS FOLLOW THAT ADVICE?
>> IF YOU DON’T HAVE TO TRAVEL
THE -- WE WANT THIS THING TO
END.
WE DON’T WANT A LOT OF PEOPLE
GETTING INFECTED.
WE WANT IT TO END AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
SO FAR I THINK WE’VE DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB.
I REALLY THINK THAT THE PEOPLE
BEHIND ME HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN
THE CREDIT THAT THEY DESERVE,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB.
WHEN YOU SEE ALL THE SCHOOL
CLOSE YOURS, THEY’RE VERY
IMPORTANT, BUT IT CAUSES A LOT
OF PROBLEMS.
THE BILL THAT WAS SIGNED
YESTERDAY TAKES CARE OF A LOT OF
THOSE PROBLEMS WITH CHILDREN
STAYING HOME, PARENTS ARE
WORKING, NOW WE TAKE CARE OF
THAT ISSUE WITH WHAT WE PASSED
LAST NIGHT.
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH THE SENATE,
AND I HAVE TO SIGN IT, BUT THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
I’M NOW GOING BACK TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
YOU HAVE GREAT PROFESSIONALS.
IF THERE’S ANYTHING THAT COMES
UP --
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I JUST WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT.
ARE YOU CONSIDERING OTHER TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS PERHAPS
DOMESTICALLY IN THAT REGARD?
>> YES.
SPECIFICALLY FOR CERTAIN AREAS,
YES, WE ARE.
AND WE’RE WORKING WITH THE
STATES, AND WE ARE CONSIDERING
OTHER RESTRICTIONS, YES.
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> REUTERS IS REPORTING THAT
YOU’RE GOING TO EXTEND EUROPEAN
TRAVEL TO THE U.K. AND IRELAND
ON MONDAY, THAT ACCURATE?
>> WE’RE LOOKING AT IT VERY
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE THEY’VE HAD A
LITTLE BIT OF ACTIVITY,
UNFORTUNATELY, SO WE’RE GOING TO
BE LOOKING INTO THAT.
WE ACTUALLY ALREADY HAVE LOOKED
AT IT, AND THAT IS GOING TO BE
ANNOUNCED.
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> IF I COULD JUST GET A LITTLE
CLARITY ON YOUR THINKING ON
THIS, IT’S BEEN A HALLMARK OF
YOUR PRESIDENCY, YOU’RE ALWAYS
GOING AFTER THE FED.
IF YOU FEEL SO STRONGLY ABOUT
IT, WHY DON’T YOU DISMISS THE
CHAIRMAN, OR DO YOU THINK YOU’RE
POWERLESS?
>> WELL, I THINK I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DO THAT OR THE RIGHT TO
REMOVE HIM AS CHAIRMAN.
HE’S, HE HAS SO FAR MADE A LOT
OF BAD DECISIONS, IN MY OPINION.
WE HAD THIS GREAT -- AND WE WILL
SOON HAVE AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS BOUNCE WHEN IT’S
OVER.
I THINK THERE’S A PENT-UP BOUNCE
THAT’S GOING TO TO BE
TREMENDOUS.
NO, I’M NOT HAPPY WITH THE FED
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THEY’RE
FOLLOWING, NOT LEADING.
WE SHOULD BE LEADING.
I’M NOT HAPPY BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CENTRAL BANKS, YOU
KNOW, OTHER CENTRAL BANKS,
LARGELY THEY’RE LOWER THAN US,
THEIR RATE, AND THEIR EQUIVALENT
OF THE FED RATE IS IS LOWER.
IN SOME CASES BY TWO POINTS.
IN SOME CASES -- THAT’S A LOT.
IN SOME CASES VERY
SUBSTANTIALLY.
AND I THOUGHT THAT THE FED WOULD
BE AND SHOULD BE MUCH MORE
PROACTIVE AS OPPOSED TO
FOLLOWING.
OUR FED IS FOLLOWING.
WE HAVE THE NUMBER ONE CURRENTLY
IN THE WORLD BY A FACTOR OF MANY
TIMES, AS YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE THE CURRENCY, WE HAVE
THE POWER, WE HAVE BY FAR THE
STRONG CURRENCY.
ALSO YOU LOOK AT THE DOLLAR, THE
STRENGTH OF THE DOLLAR.
OF OUR FED IS NOT DOING WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE DOING.
WE SHOULDN’T HAVE A FED RATE
THAT’S HIGHER THAN OUR
COMPETITOR NATIONS.
YOU LOOK AT GERMANY, THEY’RE
ESSENTIALLY UNDER ZERO.
THEY’RE NEGATIVE.
THERE ARE MANY COUNTRIES
NEGATIVE.
JAPAN’S NEGATIVE, GERMANY’S
NEGATIVE, OTHERS ARE NEGATIVE,
AND WE’RE PAYING HIGHER INTEREST
RATES.
AND WHAT I’D LIKE TO DO IS,
FRANKLY ARE, REFINANCE OUR DEBT.
WE COULD REFINANCE OUR DEBT VERY
EASILY AT A MUCH LOWER RATE.
WE HAVE SOME TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES RIGHT NOW, BUT
JEROME POWELL IS NOT MAKE IT
EASY.
NO, I HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMOVE.
I’M NOT DOING THAT, NO, I’M NOT
DOING THAT.
I HAVE THE RIGHT TO ALSO TAKE
AND PUT HIM IN A REGULAR
POSITION AND PUT SOMEBODY ELSE
IN CHARGE, AND I HAVEN’T MADE
ANY DECISIONS ON THAT.
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> MINNESOTA, WAS YOUR
TEMPERATURE -- PRIME MINISTER,
WAS YOUR TEMPERATURE -- MR.
PRESIDENT, WAS YOUR TEMPERATURE
NORMAL, MR. PRESIDENT?